in an attempt to solve to 13 thousand
year old mystery of the mammoths
extinction in North America
investigators traced the fallout pattern
of potential alien debris scattered
across the continent they are trying to
pin down the epicenter of what they
suspect was an apocalyptic cosmic impact
from specks of extraterrestrial dust a
frightening picture begins to emerge the
type of energies we're dealing with are
perhaps a hundred times out of nuclear
bombs the intensity the heat would be
incredible really all that stuff heading
down range now we're talking about
millions and billions of bullets
extending across North America
as the team matched the concentrations
of possible ET evidence the trail leads
them back to a potential impact zone
somewhere in the northeastern portion of
the continent a region that at the time
was encased in the vast Laurentide Ice
Sheet
the fact that no impact crater had been
found began to make sense to them was it
possible that thick layer of ice could
have masked the blow to the earth to
test their hypothesis
they brought out the big gun at NASA's
hypervelocity impact lab using glass
beads to simulate a comet or asteroid
planetary geologist and chief triggerman
dr. Peter Schultz fires pellets at
nearly 12,000 miles per hour into an
isolation chamber to break down the
physics of cosmic impacts this is
definitely a good suspect if you think
about a murder case
you go after probabilities events like
this have happened before every time I
do an experiment I imagine what goes on
if something like that happened then
gonna happen again
we the next victims it makes it an
imperative to find out if this really
happened
for dr. Schultz there are two possible
scenarios for a life-altering impact
that doesn't leave an obvious crater his
first shot simulates an air burst where
moments before impact the comet or
asteroid starts breaking up and
exploding into multiple fireballs as it
burns through the atmosphere see now you
can see this coming down small fragments
that's the first arrival that hits the
power if you were close enough to see
that that would be the last thing you
ever saw
we had a cloud of debris and there and a
cloud interact with the atmosphere
heating it up tremendously slammed into
the surface and created a very shallow
crater with thousands and thousands of
smaller impacts nearby and it's gonna be
extremely easy for a little bit of time
on the earth with all that water and
wind we can erase the evidence and so
we're left with nothing but the traces
of this disaster the airburst experiment
showed that by diffusing the energy at
the point of impact the blast might have
left a less obvious crater but as the
debris cloud is ejected downstream the
consequences would be no less deadly
next dr. Schultz preps the chamber for a
shot into a block of ice simulating a
two mile thick section of the Laurentide
ice sheet
[Music]
man we smashed this and you notice that
there's a very little crater hardly any
crater at all the projectile actually
went through and hit the bottom but the
critters extremely shadow the main thing
we found out in the experiment is is
that the ice acts as a shield and it
absorbed a lot of the energy a lot of
the damage as a result the earth may not
haven't been scathed the ice could have
cracked it could have crumbled when the
ice melted it would have hidden the
evidence perfectly for the mammoths
beyond the immediate impact zone it's
not the first strike that counts
it's the devastating wave of heat and
shrapnel that spewed out from ground
zero
we can see the streak come in the vapor
plume come off ejecta heading downrange
and we see these big giant blocks that
begin to break off do the shock wave
when you think about an impact do you
think about getting hit by the
projectile what's much more dangerous I
think is all that stuff heading
downrange carrying with it
vapor dust hot gas in broiling most of
North America that's the stuff that's
very scary